[Music]
we finally made it to season 8 of game
of thrones for the series of season
critiques ironically for all the videos
i made bashing season 8 i've never
actually made a full season analysis on
it for this video though we'll be going
through a coherent dive into the crazy
amount of writing flaws that david and
dan have made and we'll be determining
why game of thrones season 8 is the
magnum opus of garbage
to start out i think we should look at
the simplest and an integral aspect of
the season which is its structure and we
can snowball from there the structure of
season 8 is composed of six episodes i
think that utterly hinders the season
because with fewer episodes we can
accurately figure out what will happen
and that makes it extremely predictable
a part of the structural strength from
the earlier seasons was that they were
made up of 10 episodes so it was hard to
predict the flow of the story for season
8 though you can easily tell what each
episode will be composed of now this may
not seem overly bad per se but i think a
lot of enjoyment comes from not knowing
what will happen because we want to be
surprised and amazed but obviously not
in a bad way like killing rhaegal
randomly in an idiotic suburb
expectations kind of moment the reason
why the structure is this way in the
first place is that dave and dan wanted
to finish the show in as few episodes as
possible
which this then branches into another
issue and that the writing is flat out
rushed i went into detail about this
from my analysis on season seven but any
and all those flaws from season seven
are absolutely amplified for season
eight
and the first issue being the pace
the pace for season seven was definitely
fast but the pace for season eight is
extremely inconsistent as to how fast it
can be
let's take a look at episode 4 as an
example we start out going from a big
funeral to a dinner feast with a lot of
developments like gendry becoming the
lord of the stormlands brienne and
jaime's relationship climaxing quite
literally then to braun threatening
tyrion and jaime for highgarden jon
revealing his true identity to sansa and
arya sansa leaking this information
tyrion then leaking this information
rhaegal dying missandei getting captured
varus confirming that he's going to
betray danny and meeting up with cersei
to ask for her surrender
oh my god
and that's basically just the biggest
plot points that happened
then for the final episode the pace
drastically slows down which is kind of
jarring considering how quickly we were
moving through the plot and now we are
getting scenes with filler in them like
instead of figuring out what happens to
the dothraki as an example we get an
extended scene of tyrion fixing chairs
i definitely take having a slower pace
over speed running through the story but
if you're including scenes that have no
substance then you're just wasting
everyone's time that's ridiculous when
compared to season 2 as an example where
there's not a single moment of filler
and entire episodes are carried by
dialogue scenes alone the reason why
that was possible was that the dialogue
was riveting and had so much depth but
in season 8 the dialogue scenes lack
that much depth because david and dan
move on to other scenes very quickly an
example being jon telling daenerys that
he is a targaryen and the second she
brings up a point of conflict and jon
contesting the throne the scene abruptly
ends with the introduction of the white
walkers or looking at a smaller example
where daenerys and sansa are having a
conversation together and just when
things are heating up theon randomly
enters the scene and stops any form of
conflict confrontation
this happens quite often for a lot of
dialogue scenes and if they're actively
shortened then this aspect of the show
that inherently slows down the pace is
made ineffective
without much exploration and dialogue
and a bigger time commitment for them it
makes most of the scenes feel bland
because they only feel the basic
requirement to move the story forward
while not developing your characters
thoroughly this goes into the next side
effect of the rush writing that is by
far the most jarring and that's the
utter deterioration of dialogue
for a lot of dialogue scenes they lack
the substance and weight they had in
their earlier seasons one example being
john reuniting with arya which i was
really hyped to see them getting back
together they loved each other in season
1 and john was someone who saw arya for
who she really was and that led to some
great chemistry despite it being brief
but when you look at their reunion all
they do is hug show off their swords and
then they immediately change the subject
to sansa
the happiness of the reunion fizzles out
so quickly and devolves into an awkward
exchange of showing off their swords as
if they don't know what to say to each
other it feels like david and dan simply
just didn't know how to write this scene
so it's completely devoid of any quality
material each of these characters have
gone on such rich and dark journeys and
finally they meet back up with someone
they love but all dave and dan can
muster is a simple hug and looking at
swords
outstanding
also on the subject of substance in
terms of dialogue a lot of it is either
recycled from the earlier seasons
with a belly full of wine and a girl's
mouth around my [ __ ]
with a belly full of wine and a girl's
mouth around my [ __ ]
men decide where powell resides power
resides where men believe it resides
power is eyes where men believe shut
your mouth
feels very awkward and stupid now varys
ashes can tell my ashes
see
i told you
is only there to advance the story or is
horribly misplaced comedic relief
because i have bowls
you do
we don't have any thought-provoking
conversations that are imbued with rich
lore and character building like in most
king's landing dialogue scenes in the
earlier seasons
i only think there's one usage of a
literary device throughout season 8 and
that single line stuck out so much
because of the pure disparity in quality
the perils of self-betterment
what you like down there what
that's not your concern
the earlier seasons had literary devices
in spades and it made the dialogue feel
so witty and had a lot of meaning to be
unpacked
now it's just clear and cut basic trash
and only does the bare minimum to move
the plot forward
how did you find each other
we met up at the last half the dead got
there first
the big woman's still here
and that's assuming david and dan are
doing the bare minimum because sometimes
they don't even include dialogue scenes
where they should be or are actively
cutting them down which is really sad
due to the sheer number of characters in
winterfell
i think one of the worst letdowns in
this area that actually made me upset
was when david and dan cut away from
telling sansa and arya his true identity
this has to be the biggest blue balls of
the century like how are you going to
cut away during one of the biggest
reveals to these two characters who
loved jon their reaction alone to the
initial announcement should have been
crazy
but we don't even see how they take the
information we are left to assume how
aryan sansa reacted which is just
horrendous writing this scene should
have been an easy slam dunk but david
and dan were just too lazy to write it i
guess
and for some other examples where dave
and dan took shortcuts in terms of
dialogue scenes we never had arya
daenerys meet jamie and bran's
confrontation last less than one minute
david and dan cut away from bran and
tyrion's conversation and we never get a
dialogue scene between sansa and theon
considering they were really happy to
see each other again
at this point i don't know whether or
not david and dan were just cutting out
these scenes to rush to the end of the
show or if they genuinely can't come up
with good dialogue scenes to save their
lives
it's truly saddening that game of
thrones has stooped this slow when
dialogue used to be its strongest
attribute
going into another foundation of writing
we have story direction now the result
of the direction seems mostly natural
like the mad queen arc the living
overcoming the dead cersei and jaime's
demise and bran becoming the king
however the execution for all these big
plot points were completely ruined
for bran becoming king the entire
ceremony where he is elected exhibits a
scary level of idiocy
like the first thing being that tyrion
is electing someone off of the basis
that what makes a good king is a story
that on its own is horrible logic and
the fact that anyone is taking him
seriously is kind of shocking the public
opinion on tyrion is not good and he has
constantly feel daenerys at every turn
when he was her hand and now he's
picking the new king
if anything tyrion should have
practically no credibility and i'm
curious why grey worm even bothered to
bring him out of his cell
then when picking bran he thinks that he
has the most interesting story because
he's a three-eyed raven which
is obviously debatable but how does
anyone even know what the thread raven
means
does every lord just believe bran and no
one is confused by his powers
then there's the whole issue of no one
opposing the idea of the starks taking
full control of westeros given that
sansa will be ruling the north as an
independent kingdom
especially since yara greyjoy wanted
independence and dorne throughout the
show has also been sharing a similar
mindset so the fact that no conflict is
brought up from this decision destroys
the political undertones that used to be
in the show if this was more realistic
they would be arguing and all fighting
for their selfish desires
not just sitting back and letting the
main characters seize power without any
form of conflicts
then for the last idiotic aspect of this
scene brian alludes to seeing the future
and that is why he came all this way
which any viewer should have immediately
picked up on and would have been
confused by but the fact that this line
flies right over tyrion's head is pretty
sad for his intelligence
like bran literally just insinuated that
he let all this destruction and misery
play out just so that he could be king
but nah no consequences
this entire ending is executed in such a
sloppy and careless manner that it feels
like david and dan aren't even trying
and this is just one of four of the
major story events that they ruined in
season 8.
for the living beating the white walkers
david and dan take such a boring and
stereotypical means in finishing the
night king's storyline there is no depth
intriguing moments that extend the lore
or any twists that make the story go
into logical but unpredictable direction
it's just a generic battle that isn't
even done well since he can't physically
see anything and there's barely any good
choreography and that's pretty sad
considering past battles have seemingly
had better production values along with
having lower budgets then there's the
countless avoidalogic moments like the
dothraki charging the whites and them
while dying
especially after the characters said
they can't beat them in a straight fight
you can't beat them in a straight fight
to the horrible layout of the army like
having the trebuchets in the middle of
their layout and there being no trenches
in front of the soldiers so just name a
couple glaring flaws
to even the defenseless people of
winterfell hiding out in the crypts
where there is you know dead people
then in terms of the actual story
direction having arya kill the night
king has to be the most anticlimactic
way to kill the biggest antagonist in
the show
considering that she's never interacted
with any of the story elements related
to the white walkers
she's always been off on her own subplot
battling antagonists that were relevant
to her storyline
but her killing the night king offers no
character satisfaction of overcoming
that obstacle because she's never been
challenged by the night king throughout
her story the death because of that
feels significantly blander since there
is no cathartic explosion for arya and
overcoming him
for jon though it would be such an
overwhelmingly emotional triumph because
he has been battling the undead since
season one and the night king is
essentially his arch nemesis you can
kind of argue that arya is defeating
death as a whole which is tied to her
character but if you were to reverse the
scenario to jon suddenly killing jack
and nagar as he comes to seek vengeance
on arya or something it doesn't fit
within the story because they are
unrelated but only partially connected
via theme
according to david and dan though our
expectations need to be subverted and i
think this is a great example of doing
something unexpected to surprise the
audience at the complete detriment of
the story and you don't necessarily need
john to kill the night king but having
his demise come in a natural yet
exciting manner
also before moving on since we are on
the subject of the undead i find it
funny that david and dan didn't go into
the lore of the white locker symbols and
only said this
these are patterns that have mystical
significance for the children the forest
we're not sure exactly what they signify
but spiral patterns are important a lot
of different cultures in our world and
make sense that they would be in this
world as well
that's really sad these symbols are so
cool we just decided to include them and
they don't mean anything
moving on to the death of cersei and
jaime similar to the death of the night
king their demise also felt very
underwhelming and for the first aspect
of their demise let's look at their
relationship we see at the end of season
7 that jaime breaks off his relationship
with a manipulative cersei by choosing
to be honorable and fight for the living
which i thought that was a great
development for his character and that
perfectly aids his arc
however when looking at the scene where
jaime leaves brienne his reasoning for
going back to cersei is very flawed
i would have murdered
every man woman and child in riverrun
for cersei
she's hateful
and so am i
in that moment he refers to himself as
being in the past tense and talks about
all the bad things he has done for
cersei but that literally doesn't matter
anymore because he's changed he has
honorably defended winterfell from an
undead horde while also facing the
demons of his past
so in essence he rectified the flaws
that plagued his character and thus
becoming a better and more pure knight
and now suddenly he's like oh but i'm a
hateful man and i still love cersei i
think that's terrible and it degrades
his arc it gets even worse when david
and dan continue this trend when tyrion
decides to set him free and he says this
to be honest i never really cared much
for them
innocent or otherwise
so it just feels so contrived because
david and dan wanted jaime to go back to
cersei so they can die together but in
the process they've ruined jaime as a
character
all they had to do was have a
heartbreaking conversation where tyrion
breaks jaime's illusion of cersei being
a good person
then during that breakdown have them
come to the realization that cersei
needs to die and the best way to do so
is in jaime's loving arms
if anything it would be a mercy upon
cersei because if daenerys were to get
her hands on her then it would be a much
more painful death this also plays into
the valonqar prophecy of cersei being
killed by one of her brothers
so if cersei and jaime's death were to
play out in this manner i think their
ending would be much more cathartic and
satisfying of an ending
because currently they just briefly
reconnect jaime says the same [ __ ]
about how they are the only ones that
matter in the world again
nothing else
especially after he said that in season
six we're the only ones who must are the
only ones in this world and originally
back in season one until you and i are
the only people left in this world
pog more recycled dialogue and then they
die to a bunch of bricks how is this in
any way a good ending for your
characters jaime regresses back to where
he was in earlier seasons and cersei is
just on autopilot of shock and sadness
the whole time
there is nothing of substance
satisfaction or any groundbreaking
moment or revelation just a terrible
ending to two of the best characters in
the show
for the last big story event we'll be
looking at we have the mad queen arc for
this arc i think it mostly went pretty
well up until the end because daenerys's
main goal was to defeat cersei and to
liberate the people of king's landing
however when looking at how she carries
out that goal daenerys unjustly and for
no reason kills a bunch of innocent
people this action drastically goes
against who she fundamentally was as a
character because her main value
throughout the show has always been
saving and liberating people held under
tyranny the blood of my enemies
not the blood of innocents
and most of the time those people wanted
to be saved as well but for king's
landing the people seem to be worshiping
cersei instead and this is the main
cause that leads danny to use fear
instead of love
this whole aspect of the mad queen arc
is extremely flawed for two reasons
firstly the people of king's landing
should not be worshiping cersei at all
if anything they should be scared of her
because if she blew up the step to get
away from her enemies then what would
she do if daenerys takes hold of the
city
then for the second reason how can
daenerys be mad at the public of king's
landing for following cersei if she's
actively lying to them and telling them
that the foreigners will kill them all
which daenerys plays into like an idiot
all she had to do was destroy the red
keep and defy the expectations of her
being a crazy revenge field targaryen if
anything she would still be carrying out
her revenge but just not on the people
who did or no harm
but hey dave and dan are taking the
every time a targaryen is born you flip
a coin phrase literally and forgot that
dany is a complex character
villains aren't black and white and
george r martin made this very clear
with the primary villains being
misunderstood cersei doing anything to
protect her children talon protecting
the family's legacy at all costs or
joffrey growing up with a terrible
dysfunctional family and having to
inherit the throne at a young age
daenerys should have an equally complex
turn into being the mad queen but what
we get is an underdeveloped mess
and the biggest point of that mess being
when she snaps and destroys king's
landing because in that moment there was
no inciting incident for her to go crazy
she won the battle and was reserved in
terms of her damage output and not
killing innocents like maybe it would
make sense if the battle began with the
death of missandei and that was the
reason daenerys snapped despite david
and dan giving us barely any scenes
between dany and missandei literally one
of their only interactions throughout
season 7 and 8 was them briefly talking
about jon snow for like 10 seconds
maybe more dialogue scenes with
character relationship growth is a good
thing and not rushing to the conclusion
it would be a lot more devastating of a
death towards daenerys if missandei
actually came across as being her best
friend and she was the last piece of
normality anchoring her down to humanity
instead missandei's death scene is so
awkward especially since the objective
of that scene was to make cersei
surrender which would never happen
but yeah daenerys's mad queen arc as a
whole is illogical and it fundamentally
breaks her character at the climax along
with it not having enough build up
now that we have finished going over the
execution of the biggest points in the
story let's now talk about how david and
dan decimated the main characters of the
show this was one of the subjects for my
analysis on season 7 but i think it
would make sense to follow up on that
for season 8 considering that david and
dance somehow did an even worse job on
this season
so two characters we've already went
over with some depth is daenerys and
jaime and there's really not much more
to add since our arcs were directly tied
to their major story events
with that in mind let's look at jon snow
this poor guy has been getting railed
since season six and he hasn't had a
lick of interesting character
development since he was in love with
the egrets
now jon is stuck in a purgatory state of
mediocrity and it feels like his
emotional core is stuck in limbo
david and dan don't help in this matter
at all and essentially give jon four
dialogue options in every scene he's in
which squanders any sort of personality
he had left those options being you are
mcqueen i don't want it saying we need
some random thing for the plot and just
saying nothing and acting puzzled
every scene he's in plays like a shitty
version of a telltale game
in practically every scene in which jon
is embroiled with the subject of his
claim to the throne
he generally defaults to one of these
dialogue options i don't want it
since this is the deepest his dialogue
ever gets that translates over to having
such a shallow and hollow character
because dialogue is the best way to
express the complexities of what
motivates and drives a character and
when this is the deepest that jon goes
it's really hard to understand and
sympathize with him
if he were delivering intricate lines
that utilize outstanding literary
devices to thoroughly express how he
felt then i think jon would at least be
more interesting although that doesn't
really fix him entirely and another one
of his main problems is that he doesn't
have a good character arc this season
the main revelation for his character is
that he is a targaryen and that
basically had no lasting impact on the
plot besides making daenerys angry that
he wouldn't have sex with her anymore
and that was it because no one in the
ending ceremony even considered
pardoning jon to be the king and he just
screwed off and went north
even though the unsullied left westeros
so they wouldn't be able to make sure
jon went back to castle black which the
whole grey worm john conflict annoys me
but that's just going off topic
how the aegon arc should have gone and
what would have been the most satisfying
would be jon coming to the realization
that he needs to inherit the throne for
the good of the realm
similar to how he was assigned lord
commander and the king of the north you
can have him start out initially not
wanting it but after seeing daenerys
slowly turning go crazy he would
understand that she would be another
tyrant and he has to betray her to take
the throne for the good of the people
currently he just feels like a plot
device to kill daenerys because he does
nothing else and has no personal drive
or any form of desires
jon is one of the most selfless people
in the show and he risked everything for
the free folk and the north despite not
wanting to initially do so but when it
comes to westeros as a whole he is now
suddenly a selfish person who denies a
throne and doesn't want to help anyone
what
next we have sansa and sansa this season
is such an annoying brat the fact that
she spends the entirety of the season
just complaining about daenerys and her
army is such a childish thing to do
being openly angry with someone doesn't
seem like a smart move let alone
trashing on them when they are literally
saving your kingdom how does that
tactically help you in any way
even arya has to tell sansa that they
obviously needed help as if it wasn't
obvious
like did she think they were fine on
their own it just feels like david and
dan are forcing sons into the
stereotypical northerner that doesn't
trust anyone even though they are
clearly helping them
i know that by getting daenerys help
they'll have to repay that debt by
taking king's landing but that seems
like a pretty great deal since dany has
dragons and will be doing the heavy
lifting during the battle
then throughout the entire season sansa
only has one used to the overall story
and that's a telltarian jon's true
identity which then snowballs into varys
telling everyone without that aspect or
if you traded that scene in with tyrion
finding out that information from bran
or something sansa doesn't have much of
a use to the story this season her
running winterfell on any challenges
that incurs falls into the background
like there was an obstacle that arise
with the issue of food supply and
feeding daenerys's army but that
conflict vanishes and it was yet again
another excuse for sansa to whinge about
dany i'm not whinging
your lips are moving and you're
complaining about something that's
whinging so yeah this season makes me
lose all respect for sansa david and dan
tried to portray her as a strong
independent and smart force to be
reckoned with but any scheming skills
she learned from littlefinger seemed to
have disappeared
moving over to arya this is the only
character that isn't entirely decimated
by david and dan
they handled the revenge arc pretty well
with sandor clegane opening arya's eyes
to what revenge can do to a person it
never really felt right for arya to kill
cersei and i always felt like this was
the most natural and satisfying turn of
events for her character this is really
the only aspect in which i think david
and dan did right
because arya throughout game of thrones
has been someone who longed for family
and valued that highly her journey was
so dark and brutal and family was always
the form of normality for her character
she even found comfort in being with the
hound in season four and she literally
dropped everything to go back to
winterfell in season seven in season
eight though it feels like she could
care less about family arya's whole
reunion with jon felt awkward insulted
she barely ever interacts with bran and
they don't even have a moment of
emotional embrace after killing the
night king and arya's relationship with
sansa is practically non-existent since
they spent so much time in the conflict
between them in season 7 but spent no
time on mending their relationship in
season 8. arya even reaffirms her
position that family is important in
this scene we're family
the four of us
the last of the starks however in the
end she chooses to randomly drop
everything and become christopher
columbus
and that whole aspect about her
character feels very inconsistent and if
anything she could just ask bran to send
ravens to explore what's west of
westeros
then for gendry it feels very
disappointing that their entire
relationship builds up was just so that
arya could have sex before she possibly
died
she then cast him away as if he was
nothing and apparently loving someone
means that she has to be a lady
i mean she can easily be whatever kind
of person she wants to be while loving
gendry like that could be one of their
conditions and i'm sure gendry would
comply
i think the direction david and dan
should have taken there would be that
the reasoning arya didn't want to
permanently deal with gendry would be
because of her obsessed bloodlust for
cersei and having being broken out of
that bloodlust by sandor arya would
gravitate back to family and love not
into an unknown adventure
then finally we have cersei and to be
honest there's not much to be dissected
here because dave and dan literally gave
her nothing to do in season 8.
you have been stripped of your dignity
and authority publicly shamed and
confined to the red keep
what's left to work with her
contributions this season are
complaining about elephants killing
missandei and staring at a window for an
entire episode and that's it that's
really depressing considering that she
used to be the most layered and complex
villain in the entire show we went from
season five and six of her being a pov
character in which she had a lot of
conflict overcome to now her biggest
conflict behind the scenes being that
the golden company didn't bring
elephants
that's a striking difference and it goes
to show how shallow cersei is now
and that's about it there are obviously
major contrivances and devoted logic
aspects about season 8 that i could go
into further but i think that would make
this video over an hour long
along with those issues being
consistently present throughout most of
the points i raised in this analysis
for this series of season critiques i
still have seasons 2 and 3 left so i'll
probably go back to them soon
you